-It is so good to see you.
Congrats.
The album is finally out,
"Give or Take."
-Finally, yes.
-Finally out.
But last time we saw each other,
we had a good hang.
-Yeah, so, Jimmy and I
actually seen each other
at the past Met Gala.
-Yeah.
-We were both invited by Chanel,
so that means, pretty much,
we're at the same table.
I don't know if it's against the
rules to, like, talk too much.
-No, we can talk about it.
I mean, it was --
We were at the hottest table
at the biggest fashion night
in the history of the world.
And we were there and we hung
out all night and we bonded.
-So, and it was only my --
I say "only,"
but it was my second Met Gala.
And I don't want to,
like, tell your age,
but it was Jimmy's 19th, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it was my 19th.
But I saw you,
and you looked a little lost,
like a deer in headlights.
-Just like a deer.
But, also, the thing I remember
the most about that night --
So, we're at our table --
And I'm definitely
not getting invited back,
because I'm about
to tell all the stories.
-No, we didn't
do anything that bad.
-So, the secret performer
was Lenny Kravitz, right?
-Oh, yeah, he was amazing.
-So, Lenny comes out
and starts performing,
and everyone
is just enjoying it.
And mid-performance, I feel,
like, a tap, and it's Jimmy.
And I'm like, "What, Jimmy?"
He was like, "Do you want to
know something?"
I was like, "Right now?"
He was like, "Yeah."
He was like,
"You know, one time,
Lenny was doing a performance,
and he a wardrobe malfunction,
and, you know,
everything was out."
And I was like, "Okay."
And then Jimmy went right back
to just enjoying
the performance.
[ Cymbal crash, sad tuba plays ]
And I'm just like, "He actually
ruined the performance for me."
-What are you talking about?
-Now I'm nervous.
I'm like, "What if he rocks out
too hard tonight?"
-No, no,
I think what I was saying is,
I go, "Did you ever see that
had the wardrobe --"
He's the one dude
that could have
a wardrobe malfunction
and he was just cool with it.
-Yep.
-Because he's Lenny Kravitz.
And his stuff just came out,
and everyone was like,
"Yeah, that's kind of
what we thought," you know?
And he was like,
"Yeah, that's what's up"
and didn't care,
finished the song, you know?
Yeah, I don't even if he was,
you know,
strumming with his hand
the second half of the song.
It was unbelievable.
And --
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Vocalizes
"Are You Gonna Go My Way" ]
Yeah, hands up.
And it -- No, but I'm like,
"That dude is just the coolest."
Like, he's the sexiest.
He's just everything you think
Lenny Kravitz.
If that happened to me,
it would just be
the most embarrassing thing
that ever happened in my life.
I think I was trying to
say that to you.
-That's definitely what
you were trying to say,
but I definitely
was scared to watch
the rest of the performance.
-Come on.
-That's what happened.
But it was amazing.
-We got talking about you got
this album coming out.
Obviously, we know you have
your first number 1,
with Justin Bieber, "Peaches."
-Yes, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Were you -- Did that --
-That was pretty crazy,
because not too long ago,
I just was a server
at a restaurant --
Bubba Gump Shrimp Company.
-Yeah,
And -- But that's --
You got to start somewhere.
And I love that you did that.
-You have to. Yeah.
-Yeah, and you weren't just
a server, by the way, Giveon.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-So, since he's telling
all of my business,
I was a server, but, also,
every once in a while,
I would have to get inside
of a shrimp suit.
[ Laughter ]
-It made you who you are today.
Come on.
-It definitely
did make me who I am.
Actually, I had to
get inside of shrimp suit
and put the head on the shrimp,
the shrimp shoes,
and, like,
wave everyone in to, like,
try to convince them
to come eat there.
-Can you say anything
as the shrimp?
-In the shrimp suit,
you can't speak, right?
Because shrimp can't talk,
but I'm like,
"Shrimp don't have, like,
shoes or legs either."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I asked you --
I go, "Do you mind if --
There has to be a photo of
you as the shrimp."
-I tried to
burn, delete, destroy,
every single picture of me
as the shrimp,
but, somehow,
you guys got a picture, so...
-That's Giveon right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's how you know it is me.
I'm just...
-You're just doing that.
Oh, my gosh.
But then I was talking to you,
because I didn't want to
embarrass you,
but I was talking to you
backstage about this,
and you go -- You told me about
the one time, did you meet SZA?
-So, my third interview for
the restaurant --
Yes, third.
I don't know why Bubba Gump
requires three interviews
for some reason.
-Three interviews. Yeah, yeah.
-So, my third interview --
-You almost made it, yeah.
We don't know if
you're shrimp material.
-I'm just like, "What?"
So, I'm walking
into the third interview
and I just see SZA walking.
And I ambush her like, "Hi."
-Yeah.
-Just was
rambling out the words.
I don't even remember
everything I said,
but then I said too much.
But she was extremely nice.
But I got the job, though.
-Yeah. But then -- No, but then
this is really what happened.
But then didn't you
sing for her?
-Okay...
[ Laughter ]
-You can't jump over the desk.
-Right.
-But then you --
-Yes, I sang for her, okay?
I was gonna leave that part out.
I sang, and she was just like...
-Why would you leave it out?
-I don't know. I just --
-You're a fan.
-I was a very big fan
and still am.
I was singing for her,
and she was just like,
"This guy's singing."
-You should have done it
in the shrimp costume.
-I definitely should have,
but you're not allowed to talk.
-Oh, yeah, that's true.
Yeah, you got to be
out of character. Yeah, yeah.
-To to be quiet.
And in the suit, like --
-Yeah. Have you ever talked to
SZA about this story?
-So, she came to a show
like years later.
And I told her, and she was
like, "Oh, I don't remember."
So, I went on Instagram and
unsent the DM that I sent her.
-Wait. You DM'ed her
when you were --
-Absolutely. I was like,
"This is me, remember?
Please remember."
And then, at the show, she was
like, "I don't remember."
I went to the DM,
and it says, "2014.
Hi. My name is Giveon.
I was the kid at
Long Beach Bubba Gump.
Do you remember me?"
And I --
-Just took it off.
-I took it off.
-You're like, "I don't want any
proof of me doing that."
-So if she brings it up,
"I don't know what
you're talking about."
-Let's talk about
"Give or Take."
-"Give or Take," yes.
-Here we go.
Is it two years
in the making, at least?
-So, yeah,
two years in the making.
-Wow! That's got to feel good
to be out, huh?
-Yeah. It's a sigh of relief.
But now I think the work
kind of starts now.
-Yeah.
-I would hate to just drop it
and then just
abandon everything.
-No. No.
Which song
are you doing tonight?
-So, tonight, I'm performing
my new song, "Lie Again."
-"Lie Again."
-Yeah.
-Yeah. You know,
we saw you the other night.
I was watching
the BET Awards on Sunday.
-Oh, my God. You've seen it.
Yeah.
-Well, I noticed you had an
issue or something with sound...
-I had a technical difficulty
for sure.
-...with your performance.
And later, you tweeted that
BET sabotaged your mic.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then we heard
that you were joking.
And I just thought that maybe
if you want to right now --
to whatever camera you want to,
would you like to, Giveon,
explain yourself?
-Oh, my -- Is this the same mic?
I don't know if I trust the mic.
-You can trust us.
You can trust us.
Please explain.
-[ High-pitched ] Yes.
I was joking.
BET did not sabotage me.
-Okay. They didn't
sabotage you at all.
-[ Deeply ] No, no, not at all.
I'm positive BET supports me
and would never
purposely alter my voice.
-That sounds great.
Well, thank you
for clearing it up, everyone.
-[ Auto-tuned ] No, of course.
And, anyway...
♪ I'm happy to be here ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ So happy to be here ♪
And I know I can trust you guys,
so thank you, guys.
-Giveon, everyone.
Yeah, we would never do --
We would never.
Giveon! "Give or Take"
is available now!